first of all
what is your relationship to
award shows did you like watch them a
lot growing up
do you have any kind of memories of like
a particular host that made you think
this feels like a fun gig what do you
think about award shows in general
i loved when jimmy fallon hosted i think
it was the mtv
the vmas maybe one year and i was like
you know
working on impression i was a kid then
and i was i was
like oh how fun he's doing all these
impressions of this you know popular
singers at the time
and running around and i and i felt like
that
that looks so fun um and then i
i think it was when i saw ellen host the
oscars
i just loved that and when she was
vacuuming in the crowd
you know i i i i felt like i could see
myself doing that i always felt that
but then i yeah when i got that offer
for independent spirit awards i
i was like wow i yes i am i could see
how i'm a great host because i am
bringing a lot to the table
um i have a uh i know i hope i have a
really warm energy
and uh and silliness that i i think
i don't know i feel like i that is a
superpower of mine i feel like
bring to people and um a lot of
impressions
which is always entertaining always
people love and some singing too
so there's there's a lot to offer and i
felt you know it's pre-taped so we taped
it last week
for a couple days and i feel really
proud of myself
like it felt good that's awesome yeah
how does one get an offer to host an
awards show what is that what is that
process like
i don't know uh-huh saw me maybe it was
probably something on
snl or i'm not sure i i
feel maybe it's just through different
performances of mine through the years
maybe they're like she's ready
call her up i don't know i didn't i i
yeah really i did not expect it but that
was
but it was it's it's a very cool thing
to get to
have under my as part of my journey
that's awesome
yeah um yeah there's been
a pretty storied list of folks who have
hosted the independent spirit awards
before you melanian kroll
aubry plaza i'm curious if
you and if not with them if there's been
like a stable of other comics you've
kind of talked to
for advice on how to host things or like
things to avoid anything
like that i didn't people have asked
that
and i know i really it just went with my
gut and i trusted the
the writers who are a lot of my friends
really hilarious comics that wrote a lot
of the pieces and
you know i added my own little flavors
for like lines for
especially for certain impressions like
there's certain things that they say
i put that in there and i felt really
good about it
um but it's funny you bring that up
because there is a piece where i'm
impersonating a few of those previous
hosts so
you'll have to see that and it's kind of
that's what it's about so it's
let me try to you'll see it i don't give
away i got it i gotta gotta be patient
we gotta be patient that's true yes yes
you bring up an interesting point being
an impressionist i have to imagine
you have come across the circumstance
where people have
heard your impression of them and i'm
curious if there's ever been any kind of
like
surprising or interesting reaction to
your impression of them especially like
maybe
your castmate kate mckinnon oh yeah
i i think kate when i shared it
i think i shared that impression my
first season of snl
at its table range she's like that was
pretty good
um uh
yeah that i think a lot of people love
it there's some some celebs that
you know didn't get i remember when i
met j-lo in my writing room i
first of all so star-struck and nervous
i was like a little
little school girl what is it what is
what jim carrey says in dundalk
i feel like a little school boy again
but anyway yeah when i met j-lo i shared
my impression i was like
yeah i'm jennifer lopez my favorite
color is blue
and um she didn't laugh she just stares
at me and she goes
baby my favorite color is green everyone
knows that
and like not even i was like okay jayla
you're not
that's all right don't worry about it
um i don't know if gaga liked my
impression i've never heard anything but
majority
they'll they'll reach out and say they
love their impression you know it's it's
awesome anna navarro
it's so funny she has such a funny voice
that i
i could hear her in you know the tweets
she's
shared you know she just when i played
her on the view
yeah she she'll i firmly felt like she
tweeted something like you can imitate
me anytime you want cause that's so
funny
i love to laugh i'm not afraid of being
made fun of like someone
we know trump
um i love it it's an honor when they
when they
enjoy it i i did diane keaton the other
day on ellen
very short i'm just like oh my god
i don't know what i'm doing oh gosh i
don't know
and she reshared it and she messaged me
and i was like in heaven i was like
diane keaton
really that's cool that's i wanted to
pick my brain i messed i i slid into her
dms and i was like
diane i diane i would love to meet you
in the future whenever
and just chat i mean man
at the very least like get her fashion
advice
oh i know maybe she could give me one of
her hats exactly
you're a belt so cool
um i really enjoyed uh
a few awards seasons back year a white
male rage
yup update song and i'm curious
if you have noted any kind of similar
pattern or theme emerge from this slate
of award movies
i don't think so i feel like this was a
very diverse
i mean beautiful movies this
nominated for this year um
which is why a problem you know why i
can't imitate him
i can't you know i haven't taped
anything in minari
um uh but i i
i think it's awesome it feels really
good different stories it's nice
um refreshing
yeah there's no white i don't i can't
sing i didn't sing the white male rage
this year so yeah
it's refreshing i guess you know it's
good to not have a reason to write that
sketch
you know yeah yeah yeah uh that i have
to give credit to dan bulla
who's an amazing song a writer um but he
does a lot of the songs
and he actually wrote there's a song in
the spirit awards that you'll see
um that he wrote for me and it is
it's hilarious i hope people enjoy that
i can't wait yes uh you
you bring up a question i had about the
snl musical sketches
in general i think they have been really
special this season
um they're like legit songs right
yes and i especially enjoyed using the
hook on boomer scott the vax
oh my gosh yeah that was all chris red
in his bud
chris does so many good signs yeah i i'm
curious what is the
process like from you know farm to table
so to speak of putting together a
musical sketch for snl
and getting that like ready for the
radio kind of sheen for it
well it's like any other sketch where
you bring it to the table read
you'll rehearse it a few times with eli
who who plays the music
and and then does well at table it
it goes right and that night they start
prepping for the pre-tape
uh i mean i i only the only one i
personally did was the hobby song
with andrew dismukes he was when he was
a writer that season
um and i didn't think it would go well
at table i was like i just want to write
a song about
how much i i love my hobbies um
and and it went well but it was it's
pretty magical to see it all come
together like the whole crew
they copy they got they found pictures
of my apartment
and they bought a lot of the same things
and made the room look like my apartment
i was like
this is so cool um
but i yeah that this year i was just
singing yesterday about eggo's song
local
that song is so good
yeah i was so proud of her too
that was great and then bad bunny has a
plan
i mean those yeah they've had some good
songs this year
that's dope um you
have a book on the way the concept which
really intrigues me uh
can you explain what like a creative
self-help journal
kind of means for you it intrigues me
yeah well
i do a lot of art and there's now i've
been gathered
there's i feel like a lot of fans now
that appreciate my art
and uh i've done like the past year
art prints and stuff and everyone's
always like make a book
please make a book um and yeah you know
i was thinking
i felt like last year too i felt well i
grew up loving shel silverstein
as a kid i always felt like yeah they're
dark but there's also
i don't know there's some simplicity to
it so my art's very similar to his
and um i personally love so i have so
many self-help books
uh and i thought well let's put my art
in a book
and also connect it with personal
stories
and activities for people to get in
touch with their
their loony side i think that's the core
of my comedy is
how to be your own best friend and how
to make yourself laugh alone
and i yeah so that's what i feel like
that's what it all is my
my drawings are very about
they're they're about self-love and um
tenderness and vulnerability and
yeah that i think that's what it's going
to be
can you say the title of it yet or is
that still under wraps no we're still
figuring it out but i'm leaning towards
be a good nut
uh well there was something my dad said
one time i was kind of beating myself up
i was like dad sometimes i look in the
mirror and i just think god look at this
loony
mess and he said but you're the right
kind of loony
and i was like oh that's cool that's a
good
so it might be like right kind of loony
or something like
where you can accept all the mess and
just be a loony
happy loony that's really sweet i can't
wait to read that
thanks thank you um you touched on
something interesting you mentioned like
the
the strength of being able to laugh
alone
which we've all goodness sort of been
doing a lot during the quarantine
but you are heading back on tour this
summer
the california girls stand-up tour what
does that feel like
emotionally to kind of prepare yourself
to be in front of a crowd again
do you feel like your style's going to
change how is that
sort of percolating in your mind well
yeah i feel nervous that
i'm going to be rusty but you know i did
a show this past weekend
just one night in this pump in palm
springs
uh my friend jack show and it was very
limited amount of people and spread out
and
but i was surprised i was very proud of
myself it like didn't go away the
the rustiness wasn't there it was i felt
pretty good about myself so
i think it's going to be fun going on
the road and i hope yeah i'm hoping that
the hour gets you know stronger and in
good shape by the time i get to la to
tape the california girl special
um but i hope i get new bits along the
way
too you know uh just that nice mix of a
lot of old stuff that people love
a lot of old impressions too like none
of it has been on a special or a comedy
album and
it's time to just let those
let that the babies you know fly oh
that's a weird phrase uh but you know
let the babies fly the thing people say
yeah
well yeah it's exciting to give like
this it's almost like a present of
everything i
create have worked on for a long time
now
you know doing stand-up and just my
point of view
and who i am it's really special
and what's cool about this tour is i'm
going to be donating the proceeds a lot
of it to the clubs themselves
so it's just that'll feel good too it's
like being
just being a good being a good person
feels good absolutely because they've
been hit
they've been hit so hard by yeah so sad
yeah
and a lot of those clubs i mean they
they've taken great care of me over the
years and
you know yeah so it's it's gonna i think
it's gonna feel
very good to my soul
awesome um moving back to the
independent spirit awards for a bit
um you know i've heard a lot of
folks who've hosted like the oscars say
it's a bit of a
tight rope you have to be funny you have
to have a take but you don't want to
like
ruffle the feathers of the you know the
illuminati or whoever
uh and i'm curious if you felt like
there was a similar
tightrope you had to walk or did you
feel like you could be a little more
irreverent
did being pre-taped change that in any
way oh maybe
maybe that did everything felt right to
me and
and fun i think if there was something
that was stumbling i had a film that
didn't feel good i probably would have
said something
but thankfully like i said a lot of
these comedians that were right that
wrote the scripts and stuff they already
knew my voice so well
and the delivery and my there's a
lightness
to my comedy i've never done anything
political or dark i i
you know i'm just not i'm more in the
silly town so they made it in that way
and and i think
that's why it feels good i i didn't even
think about worrying about anything
yeah that's great i love silly town um i
got time for one more question with you
uh and you know if i'm putting you on
the spot i apologize but you are such
a good impressionist we have spoken with
each other for about 15 minutes
yeah do you have like a first draft
impression of me
like what am i like what would your take
on me be
um do you have a first draft
no i don't have but i know you you smile
like that you go you have a little smile
right away and i
i like that um i'm sorry i haven't
gotten anything
right now no that's okay no i'm just
unmemorable that's fine
no no but i better hung out with you for
an hour or something
that definitely would start is that
about how much time it takes
like to research i think so maybe an
hour a couple hours
of hearing the person watching them for
intently
you know yeah i think so that makes
sense
awesome thanks so much for your time
really appreciate it greg you're awesome
appreciate it have a nice day
you too back at you